AS THE RACE FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
HEADS INTO THE POST LABOR DAY
STRETCH, JOE BIDEN SAYS HE WILL
RESUME IN PERSON CAMPAIGNING,
MAKING STOPS IN KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES AFTER TAKING HIS CAMPAIGN
ALMOST ENTIRELY ONLINE DURING
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
NEW POLLS SHOW BIDEN LEADING
AMONG LIKELY VOTERS IN THREE
STATES WITH NINE-POINT LEAD IN
ARIZONA.
FOR IN NORTH CAROLINA AND
EIGHT-POINT LEAD IN WISCONSIN.
LET’S BRING IN CARL.
A SENIOR ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH.
CARL, WE ARE ABOUT A WEEK SINCE
THE REPUBLICAN CONVENTION CLOSE,
IS IT TOO EARLY TO LOOK AT THE
POLLS AND SAY WHERE THE CAMPAIGN
IS SHAKING OUT?
CARL: I’D WAIT A COUPLE DAYS
MORE.
WE ARE NOW STARTING TO GET HOLES
OUT AND INTO THE FIELD SUNDAY
NIGHT AND I FEEL BETTER ABOUT
THE POLLS THIS WEEK THAN THOSE
OVER THE WEEKEND.
THERE’S BEEN A MINOR TYPE RACE
BUT IT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME
TIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLITICS
AVERAGE, THE BIGGEST GAP WAS
JUST OVER 11 POINTS JUNE 22 AND
TODAY IT’S ABOUT 7.2 SO THERE’S
A TIGHTENING BUT IT’S BEEN GOING
ON FOR A WHILE.
PAUL: THAT MEANS THERE’S STILL A
SUBSTANTIAL LEAD NATIONWIDE FOR
BIDEN AND LESS IN THE
BATTLEGROUND STATES THE USE OF
THE SURVEY, NINE POINTS IN
ARIZONA, EIGHT IN WISCONSIN.
THE PRESIDENT ONE ARIZONA LAST
TIME.
CARL: I WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS ON
THE STATE LEVEL POLLS, THESE ARE
FOX POLLS SO WE HAD GREATER
CONFIDENCE IN THOSE SCHOOLS SO
I’M LOOKING AT PRIVATE DATA
SENATE RACES FOR EXAMPLE,
ARIZONA AND NORTH CAROLINA AND
THEY SHOW THE RACE AND SMALL
LEAD, WE SAW A PUBLIC POOL IN
NORTH CAROLINA THIS WEEK THAT
HAD THE RACE DEAD EVEN.
WE HAVE A LOT MORE NATIONAL
POLLS SO WE CAN CONSTRUCT AN
AVERAGE THE AVERAGE GIVES US A
BETTER SENSE OF WHERE THE RACE
IS.
WE DON’T HAVE AS MANY STATE
LEVEL POLLS.
IS THE PRESIDENT BEHIND IN
STATES WHERE HE SHOULD BE AHEAD?
YES, HE WON WITH CAROLINA IN
WISCONSIN AND HE’S GOT SOME WORK
TO DO BUT BE CAREFUL ABOUT
READING TOO MUCH INTO ONE
INDIVIDUAL STATE LEVEL POOL.
PAUL: WE’LL SEE WHERE THAT
SHAKES OUT IN THE NEXT TEN OR SO
DAYS.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THIS LAW AND
ORDER ISSUE IN URBAN UNREST.
THE PRESIDENT IS OBVIOUSLY
TRYING TO MAKE IT A MAJOR THEME.
JOE BIDEN IS ON THE DEFENSIVE
WHERE HE STARTS TALKING ABOUT IT
BUT IS IT MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THE RACE?
KARL: I THINK THE CHANGE IN THIS
RACE GOING TO COME BY BUILDING
ISSUE UPON ISSUE UPON ISSUE TO
BREAKING.SO WILL IT HELP THEM
GET TO THE BREAKING.?
IT BOILS DOWN TO JUDGMENT.
HIS JOE BIDEN TO WEEK TO ADDRESS
THIS?
IS JOE BIDEN WRONG IN FAILING TO
ADDRESS IT?
IT WAS REMARKABLE, IT PASSED AN
ENTIRE WEEK WITHOUT MENTIONING
ONCE THE LAWLESSNESS IN AMERICAN
CITIES.
I THOUGHT BIDEN WAS SMART TO,
AND SAY I CONDEMN CERTAIN TERMS
THE LAWLESSNESS THAT’S GOING ON
IN OUR CITIES, PEOPLE MUST BE
PUNISHED.
THEN TURNED AROUND AND
DIMINISHED SAYING THIS IS ALL
DONALD TRUMP.
HE’S RESPONSIBLE FOR WHICH I
THINK IS SAYS TO SOMEBODY IN THE
SUBURBS, THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WE HAVE UP FOR GRABS IN THE
ELECTION.
THEY ARE SAYING I LIKE WHAT
TRUMP HAS DONE BUT I DON’T LIKE
THE WAY HE HANDLES HIMSELF.
WHEN BIDEN SAYS IT’S ALL HIS
FAULT, THEY SAY WAIT A MINUTE,
IT’S NOT HIS FAULT, IT’S THE
FAULT OF THE INDIVIDUALS
PROVIDED PICK UP BRICKS AND
THREW THEM THROUGH THE WINDOWS
AND TOOK COCKTAILS AND THREW
THEM.
IT’S THEIR FAULT, NOT DONALD
TRUMP’S FAULT.
IT OVERWHELMED IT, PEOPLE SIMPLY
LEFT IT ALONE AND HE SAID I
CONDEMN AND ON NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS WHAT’S GOING ON, POLICE
MUST HUNT DOWN THOSE PEOPLE AND
THEY MUST BE PROSECUTED.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER THAN
TO MAKE IT ENTIRELY POLITICAL
AND SAYING JUST REMEMBER, IT’S
DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
PAUL: THE OTHER, ONE OF THE
THEMES RELATED TO THIS IS THIS
IDEA BIDEN IS WEAK, HE’S NOT
TOUGH ENOUGH TO HANDLE THIS KIND
OF UNREST.
OF COURSE HE’S ON YOUR WATCH SO
WHO IS WEAK AND WHO IS IT?
I WONDER IF THE SUBTEXT RELATES
TO WHETHER BIDEN IS GOING TO BE
STRONG ENOUGH AND WILLING TO
STAND UP TO THE POLITICAL LEFT
WHICH HAS BEEN DRIVING SO MUCH
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SPEAK.
KARL: I THINK THAT’S SOMETHING
WE WILL SEE PLAYED OUT IN THE
NEXT SEVEN OR EIGHT WEEKS.
HE’S DONE THINGS THAT HAVE
ASTONISHED ME.
HE IMMEDIATELY SAID LET’S SIT
DOWN AND WRITE 100 PLUS PAGE
PAPER ON HOW I’M GOING TO
CONCEDE TO YOU ON MOST MAJOR
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND POLITICAL
AND MILITARY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES.
THAT DOCUMENT, THE UNITY
COMMISSION REPORT THAT THEY
SIGNED OFF ON AN ASTONISHING
SURRENDER TO THE LEFT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT’S THE MOST LIBERAL U.S.
SENATE RUNNING MATE, HAS SENT
THINGS YOU WOULDN’T HAVE SAID
TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO AND MAYBE
DIDN’T EVEN SAY A YEAR AGO.
PAUL: I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THE JOBS NUMBERS IN THE ECONOMY
THIS WEEK BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
THE ECONOMY IS RECOVERING FASTER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WOULD.
MOST PEOPLE ON WALL STREET
THOUGHT IT WOULD.
WE ARE STILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE TOO
MANY PEOPLE OUT OF WORK BUT IT’S
RECOVERING FASTER.
HOW STRONGLY WOULD YOU HIT THIS
ISSUE IF YOU WERE THE PRESIDENT.
KARL: I’D BE HITTING IT HARD AS
YOU GO IN SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER,
I’D BE HITTING IT HARD BECAUSE
YOU GOT TO MAKE OF IT.
HIS CAMPAIGN HAS TO MAKE A BUT
AS WE GET FURTHER INTO THE FALL,
CORONAVIRUS RECEIVED FROM ITS
POSITION AS THE MAJOR CONCERN.
PEOPLE BEGAN TO TURN THEIR
ATTENTION TO WHO’S BETTER ABLE
TO REIGNITE THE ECONOMY, THIS IS
WHERE HE HAS HAD AN EDGE OVER
BIDEN.
I READ THE DISPATCH EVERY
MORNING BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
CHART AT THE TOP THAT SHOWS THE
SEVEN-DAY ROLLING AVERAGE FOR
CASES SEVEN-DAY ROLLING AVERAGE
FOR DEATHS.
WE ARE DOWN 50% FROM THE HIGHS
WE HAD EARLIER THIS SUMMER ON
CASES WE ARE ONE THIRD THE LEVEL
OF DEATHS.
NOT TO DIMINISH HOW TERRIBLE IT
IS THAT 1000 OR SO WEEK ARE
DYING BUT WE ARE DOWN TO A THIRD
OF WHERE WE WERE IN MAY SO THAT
CONTINUES, THE ECONOMY WILL BE A
BIGGER ISSUE IN THE MINDS OF
VOTERS.
PAUL: THAT’S ABOUT 1000 A DAY.